parler de la contestation politique et
de ce qu'a dit général Darmanin sur ces
projets de bassines sur le sur le fond
et parce que vous comprenez ces
agriculteurs qui disent ben nous on va
stocker l'eau tant qu'il y en a parce
qu'avec la sécheresse on peut plus
régler nos cultures oui je les comprends
bah ils défendent leur métier ils
défendent leur activité je crois que de
toute manière le sujet il est c'est un
sujet qui est d'abord un sujet de monter
de toutes pièces pour faire un débat
politique et puis pour faire une cause à
défendre mais sinon je vois pas ce qu'il
y a toutes les études montrent que les
bassines notamment celle de cette région
là n'ont pas vraiment d'impact
écologique grave au contraire je dirais
que ça défend une activité qui est une
activité tout à fait essentielle pour la
France et pour cette région ça c'est une
solution c'est une pierre pour
l'agriculture et pour aider les
agriculteurs face à ces périodes de
sécheresse ça pourrait être une solution
si ça participait justement d'une d'une
pluralité d'exploitation on voit bien
que c'est super bassines sont aussi
liées à des exploitations d'ordre
productivistes intensives et qui
évidemment fâche les écologistes et je
les comprends parce qu'on nous explique
aujourd'hui qu'il faut vivre dans un
monde beaucoup plus éthique beaucoup
plus sobre et que ces grandes
exploitations qui nécessitent énormément
d'irrigation et donc l'appel à de l'eau
viaatiques font que ces projets doivent
être questionnés interrogés à minima
est-ce que dit ces écologistes depuis
toujours d'ailleurs souvent on les a
souvent on leur a souvent reproché leurs
engagements rappelez-vous à José
Beauvais les chauffeurs les fauchage
d'egm ou même la destruction du
McDonald's on les prenait un peu pour
des fous en fait je trouve et ça a été
dit par le confrère journaliste il les
écologistes attirent l'attention je
pense que personne en France n'avait
entendu parler de ces histoires de
bassine à part dans certaines régions de
France où c'est le ou c'est le cas et
donc c'est bien que ces sujets là soient
portés à l'échelle nationale qu'il y a
un débat et là c'est comme le disait
votre mode confrère journaliste c'est
souvent quand il y a des violences ce
que l'on se met à discuter de ces sujets
là rappelez-vous Emmanuel Macron a
renoncé deux fois à des grands projets
ça a été Notre Dame des Landes et la
taxe carbone et ça c'est fait juste
après des faits de violence donc c'est
dommage que c'est des barres
interviennent effectivement après ce
type d'événements
puisque ça a pris une tournure politique
avec des violences lors d'une
manifestation interdite une soixantaine
de Jordan de gendarmes blessés pardon et
Gérald Darmanin miser intérieur qui a
réagi on va l'écouter
ce qui s'est passé relève de
manifestations extrêmement violente je
veux redire que cela relève de l'écho
terrorisme il y a des gens qui fichent
c'est-à-dire radicaliser pour les
services de renseignement français pour
l'ultra gauche va le manifestement le
désordre et le chaos et nous ne pouvons
l'accepter et la maferme de l'État sera
évidemment au rendez-vous et je crois
que tous les responsables politiques
devraient les devraient les dénoncer je
m'étonne que l'ordre républicain n'est
pas été soutenu par toutes
terrorisme Yves le moins fort il est
justifié de la part de Gérald Darmanin
j'ai toujours du mal quand on emploie le
mot terrorisme et quand on détourne de
sa vocation première qui est celle
d'actes qui sont vraiment incomparable
singulier et
c'est de l'écho des vacances ça c'était
c'est très clair c'est de la délinquance
c'est une façon de
d'attirer l'attention sur soi de façon
détestable je trouve et qui violent
effectivement l'ordre républicains qui
n'a aucune aucun motif aucune motivation
recevable je dirais autant je suis
d'accord pour qu'il y ait un débat sur
notre façon de d'aller vers l'écologie
et davantage de protection de
l'environnement alors qu'on pèse pas
grand chose d'ailleurs à l'échelle de la
planète il faut quand même le souligner
et qu'on est assez peu pollueur mais ces
histoires qui me font penser parce que
moi je suis un peu plus vieux que vous
là à tous mais bon c'est pas nouveau ce
qu'ils font moi j'ai connu de l'arzac
j'ai connu tout ça bon c'est on sait que
c'est du c'est du militantisme qui agite
n'ont pas le drapeau vert d'ailleurs
mais qui hésite le drapeau noir et qui
veulent aller à castagne
je suis stupéfé par les propos de mais
parce que
[Musique]
tout à l'heure qui nous dit ah oui mais
c'est les Black Bloc bah oui mais c'est
les Black Blocs mais vous saviez que les
Black Blocs seraient là donc de toute
manière ils sont complices vous
connaissez qu'on peut leur dire merci
aux écologistes qui ont été un moment
donné dans l'histoire
en état d'arrestation qu'ils ont été
désobéissants je vous parlais de José
Beauvais tout à l'heure heureusement
j'imagine que vous êtes satisfait que
vos enfants vos petits-enfants ne
dépanne dans leur assiettes j'imagine
que vous êtes satisfait de la part de de
des actions de José ouais pas du tout
vous êtes satisfait de pas manger de
gemmes j'imagine aujourd'hui je peux en
manger sur Paris un moment donné
il y a dans l'histoire des gens qui se
sont mis en danger face à la loi je
pense notamment au féministe quand elles
ont porté la loi sur la livg quand elles
ont signé le manifester 343 vu
que je veux dire c'est que le mouvement
de désobéissance à un moment donné est
forcément vivent à stigmatiser des
personnes qui se mettent en en retrait
ou en tout cas qui se mettent en
difficulté vis-à-vis de la loi or là
justement précisément on voit bien qu'il
y a des écologistes depuis des dizaines
d'années alerte sur des sujets qui sont
des sujets de
qui sont qui sont non plus non plus là
vous parlez de militants écologiste
a toujours cette indignation sélective
on a vu dans les rues de France la
semaine dernière je sais pas c'est ce
qui me paraît plus logique mais même
pardon on parle de vous confondez des
militants une poignée de militants black
bloc qui viennent effectivement en
découdre qui viennent en découpe avec la
police et il y a des militants
écologistes on s'interroge pourquoi une
député bien sûr à un endroit où le
mauffisant est interdite pardon mais si
une député ne peut pas venir soutenir
des mobilisations écologistes qui ont
vocation à soutenir un développement
durable une agriculture biologique une
agriculture de proximité etc c'est leur
boulot c'est dommage sur le terrain
de la nation sélective je parlais des
manifestations
d'extrême droite
néo-faciaste qui était défilé on parle
de quoi pardon mais je vous avais
entendu Darmanin vous sur ça là il y a
un danger imminent pour la France
parlant
et un mieux vivre et un mieux une
meilleure agriculteur c'est sûr que eux
ils font le travail des militants et des
milices d'extrême droite ça c'est
évident il faut leur boulot bah les
militants écologistes qui se mêlent au
Black Bloc ça c'est sûr il faut le lit
de l'extrême droite mais de façon on y
va droite au but on y va droite bien sûr
c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils sont
responsabilités qui gouvernent
aujourd'hui
ils savent très bien que ce qu'ils font
non non
pour vous c'était la place de
parlementaire d'aller dans une
mobilisation interdite à partir du
moment où la conviction qui est celle
des députés qui consiste à dire non il y
a un danger écologique sur ce lieu là et
d'être présent sur place j'ai pas vu la
députée écologiste ou là on découvre on
découvre comme le disait votre
journaliste le journées tout à l'heure
vis-à-vis des forces de l'or non elle
vient en soutien une mobilisation et
heureusement encore une fois qu'il y a
eu des responsables politiques qui ont
pris des risques face à la loi notamment
pour dénoncer des des aberrations
écologiques comme celle-ci ça veut dire
que quand à la fin de son propos ou
qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure géralder
Manin dit ne pas comprendre que tous les
responsables politiques ne condamnent
pas ce qui s'est passé ce week-end à
Sainte-Souline vous n'êtes pas d'accord
il disait Jean-Luc Mélenchon il faisait
Sandrine Rousseau
sélective moi j'aurais aimé que Monsieur
Darmanin s'offusque des manifestants qui
peuvent encore manifester en France au
nom d'un néo fascisme d'un néo-nazisme
qui qui se laisse
qui se laisse porter sans que le
discours de Monsieur dermanence soit
fort et ferme donc non moi je comprends
pas cette je vois bien que Monsieur
Darmanin a un problème avec ses députés
de la nuit Pesse ou en tout cas cette
majorité alternative qui est en train de
se construire et que c'est aujourd'hui
sa source de préoccupation avant même
celle de l'extrême droite et ça ça me
pose une question effectivement sur les
objectifs réels du ministre de
l'intérieur vous voyez c'est vrai que le
haschiste s'apporte de Paris c'est vrai
j'avais oublié excusez-moi mais c'est
vraiment incroyable je crois qu'on y va
tout droit malheureusement
vous voulez absolument que le
rassemblement national et là vous me
trouverez vous me trouverez contre vous
et contre le rassemblement national vous
voulez absolument qu'il gouverne ce pays
vous faites tout pour tout pour c'est ce
qui va se passer d'ailleurs en 2027 je
vous fiche mon billet aux élections à
l'élection présidentielle la seule
alternative ça sera Madame Le Pen merci
Monsieur Mélenchon et merci tous ceux
qui parce que vous ne savez pas vous ne
savez défendre votre cause on parle de
ce qui s'est passé insolite en quoi ce
qui s'est passé à Sainte-Catherine
participe le mouvement écologiste
participe passé
des étrangers des manifestations
d'extrême droite alors que on est sur
Assassin's personne pas même le
gouvernement mais pardon ben oui quand
on décide qu'aujourd'hui de dire que la
nouvelle Première ministre ah ben non il
y a eu tous des bases que c'est une
fasciste pas facile c'est qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui elle ne
m'amuse qui a porté le brassard nazi bon
bah pardon oui le fascisme est là il est
présent aujourd'hui
à l'arrivée d'extrême droite je l'ai été
sans doute bien avant vous aussi pardon
oui pardon bah oui pardon le combat
contre le combat contre certes vous êtes
ah oui
je suis sûr que dans les boules bien sûr
je vous dis je vous lis et je vous
entends le discours qui consiste
aujourd'hui à nous expliquer que
l'extrême droite serait tout à fait
normalisée aujourd'hui par le discours
d'une marine Le Pen qui va bien
l'écologie c'est ce que je dis c'est
vrai que ça va dans le sens de l'extrême
droite absolument pas ce que je dis on
va dire un mot de l'écologie après on va
reparler de la nuque hein ça ça va vous
je sens que ça va encore vous diviser la
question de la nuque et un mot sur
l'écologie puisque aujourd'hui le
gouvernement présente à la fois son
texte pour accélérer le nucléaire ça
s'est en conseil des ministres et des
fonds son texte pour accélérer les
énergies renouvelables ce sera cet
après-midi au Sénat sorte de en même
temps de la politique énergétique
d'Emmanuel Macron Mathias
avec 40% de besoins supplémentaires en
électricité d'ici à 2050 la France doit
repenser son modèle et la clé pour
produire cette électricité de manière la
plus décarbonée
la plus sûre
la plus souveraine et justement d'avoir
une stratégie plurielle développer tout
à la fois les énergies renouvelables et
le nucléaire prudent vis-à-vis de
l'atome en 2018 le président de la
République annonce 4 ans plus tard un
vaste plan de relance du nucléaire
civile la construction de six nouveaux
EPR a horizons 2035 ainsi que la
prolongation de la durée de vie du
parking existant un choix assumé du
nucléaire en même temps que l'ambition
affichée du développement massif des
énergies renouvelables pour aller plus
vite sur ces projets Emmanuel Macron et
son gouvernement souhaitaient les
procédures aller plus vite c'est d'abord
mobiliser le foncier sur lequel
aujourd'hui il est interdit de poser des
panneaux photovoltaïques par exemple ce
qu'on appelle les délaissés routiers
c'est également accélérer certaines
procédures sans rien retirer de notre
droit de l'environnement mais tout
simplement éviter d'avoir des procédures
qui s'enchaînent et alors qu'elle
pourrait être mener de front d'ici à
2050 le président a annoncé vouloir une
cinquantaine de parcs éoliens en mer et
une multiplication par 10 de la
production solaire en France les
énergies renouvelables représentent
aujourd'hui en moyenne 24% du mix
énergétique on est dans une sorte de en
même temps il va à la fois on développe
le nucléaire et puis on développe le
renouvelable c'est tenable c'est
nécessaire
après si vous voulez je suis pas sûr que
pour ce qui concerne le texte du
nucléaire ça soit un texte c'est un
texte qui cherche à faciliter les
procédures c'est pas un texte de fond en
fait ça c'est la première des choses
après sur les énergies renouvelables
c'est un vrai je trouve que là c'est un
vrai débat un débat très intéressant
l'éternel débat sur les les éoliennes
avec la défiguration du paysage
évidemment qu'il faut prendre en compte
quand même bon il faut de toute manière
qu'on avance sur ce terrain là c'est
évident et
je connais pas encore le détail des
textes si vous voulez donc je me
garderai bien d'avoir un avis trop
affirmatif mais il faut impérativement
que ce débat existe de notre pays pour
qu'on avance parce que on a pris
beaucoup de retard et les deux textes
effectivement visa simplifier les
procédures à la fois pour développer
renouvelables et pour développer le
nucléaire c'est compatible pour vous
pierre oui alors moi je vois en même
temps un peu plus sournois quand même
parce qu'il y a le en même temps
d'Emmanuel Macron qui dit sur le
nucléaire c'est l'État qui va imposer
aux collectivités en faisant aussi des
règles d'urbanisme et donc parce que
l'État se porte garant sur la conformité
des installations et puis sur le quand
même oui il y a des consultations enfin
sur les sur la manière dont on va
construire et où on va construire les
opère visiblement l'État en tout cas
c'est ce qui est prévu effectivement
pour faciliter les procédures et pour
aller plus plus vite parce que bon on
est dans une échéance on décide
maintenant mais le père verra pas le
jour avant 2035 voir 2040 parce qu'on
sait très bien que tout ça prend
beaucoup de temps et surtout beaucoup
d'argent et que de l'autre côté quand il
s'agit de la question du du renouvelable
peut-être qu'on va laisser les élus
locaux décider si oui ou non on peut
installer des panneaux solaires pas
l'installer des de l'éolien en plus avec
l'amendement de la droite au Sénat qui
prévoit peut-être on va je sais pas je
crois pas encore que le gouvernement est
donné son avis sur la possibilité des
élus de donner à droite de veto à
l'installation de ce pas très favorable
pas du tout
je sais pas parce que bon j'imagine
qu'il espère avoir les voix de la droite
sur sur un projet comme celui-là enfin
j'imagine que le gouvernement espère
avoir les voix une majorité pour voter
ce texte parce que ce serait quand même
fâcheux que il y a un recours abusif
aussi au 49-3 sur des textes comme ce
comme celui-là donc
je vois eux en même temps en tout cas de
on fait confiance aux élus locaux d'un
côté et de l'autre côté on dit c'est
l'État qui s'impose après
sur le mix moi je pense que c'est la
bonne solution je sais ce fameux en même
temps qui est là pour la peine ne
fonctionne bien sur la question
écologique d'Emmanuel Macron un peu de
nucléaire un peu d'éolien un peu de
solaire un peu d'hydraulique c'est le
mix énergétique sur lequel à mon avis
l'ensemble des des grandes régions des
grands territoires de ce monde doivent
pouvoir manœuvrer pour pouvoir aboutir à
une peut-être une forme d'indépendance
même si la question du nucléaire tout à
l'heure ça a été rappelé par le député
tâcher ne nous permet pas d'être
totalement indépendant parce que ça
dépend effectivement de l'uranium qu'on
fait qu'on importe mais je trouve que il
y a un débat qu'on n'a pas sur la
question écologique et notamment sur la
question de l'alimentation en énergie
c'est la question des des territoires
on dit que l'État doit faire beaucoup et
c'est nécessaire c'est lui qui doit
impulser des politiques comme la
question de du renouvelable mais vous
voyez des détails comme l'État de la
Californie même si c'est des des États
qui sont pas comparables à des régions
comme la France mais la Californie a
réussi à être 100% autonome et
renouvelable en termes de production
d'énergie donc on date des capacités
comme s'il y a une volonté politique
qu'on devrait avoir des capacités c'est
vrai que vous l'avez rappelé la France
est extrêmement en retard et que au
moins ce que est en train de faire
Emmanuel Macron c'est de dire là on y va
très fort On y va très fort mais sans
donner les moyens financiers savoir
voilà est-ce qu'il va y avoir des des on
sait très bien par exemple un panneau de
dépanneaux solaires c'est de 5 à 10 ans
pour installer des panneaux solaires je
crois que l'éolien non c'est l'éolien 5
à 10 ans les panneaux solaires c'est un
peu plus donc entre les procédures
administratives la possibilité pour par
les élus locaux de refuser peut-être de
faire installer des des du renouvelables
dans leur périmètre fait qu'il y a aussi
quand même tout un travail à faire de
pédagogie auprès des populations et ça
ça peut pas se faire tout seul il faut
des moyens la question un peu plus
politique qui puisque pierre le disait
il va falloir trouver une majorité
évidemment sur ce texte alors est-ce que
c'est du côté de la droite la droite
sénatoriale elle défend les élus locaux
et ce droit de veto des îles locaux le
gouvernement y est opposé ou est-ce que
c'est du côté des écologistes et est-ce
que ce dont on parlait précédemment à
savoir ce qui s'est passé ce week-end à
Sainte-Souline peut priver le
gouvernement des voies des écolos
on va voir ça va être un marchandage le
problème du gouvernement c'est que texte
par texte bon là c'est parce que c'est
un texte effectivement qui fait appel
comme tous les textes il va faire appel
à chaque fois à la droite à la gauche
bon ça va être un marchandage est-ce que
le gouvernement va accepter des
amendements c'est toujours le même le
même sujet la seule chose c'est est-ce
que sur ce sujet là sur ce front là il
va sortir le 49-3 alors qu'il va avoir
besoin du 49-3 par ailleurs si je ne
m'abuse pour notamment commencer la
réforme pour la réforme des retraites
est-ce que il va se priver de 49-3 dans
ce cadre là donc si ce prix du 49-3 il
va falloir qu'il fasse effectivement ça
va être des marchandages à non plus
finir ça va être très compliqué pour les
oppositions effectivement de s'opposer à
un texte comme celui-là qui est censé
quand même sur un mix énergétique et
c'est sur la question de la forme je le
disais sur l'interventionnisme de l'État
dans les endroits où les élus locaux ont
envie d'avoir leur pré carré réservé et
on va parler la position justement
puisque lundi deux motions de censure
ont de nouveau été déposées par leur
rassemblement national et par la France
insoumise c'était sur le budget de la
Sécurité sociale les deux ont été
rejetés le budget de la Sécu et donc
adopté à l'Assemblée mais l'une de ces
deux motions continue à faire parler oui
c'est la motion de censure déposée par
les insoumis à la recueilli 218 voies on
rappelle que 289 était nécessaire pour
faire tomber le gouvernement le texte
des insoumis dénoncé un simulacre de
démocratie parlementaire organisé par le
gouvernement sur les textes budgétaires
alors qu'est-ce qui fait parler et bien
c'est ce message ce texte posté par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon hier sur son blog il
accuse les députés de gauche n'ayant pas
voté la motion de soutenir Emmanuel
Macron sous prétexte de refuser les voix
RN il finissent en fait sans oser le
dire par soutenir le gouvernement Macron
en refusant sa chute voilà c'est écrit
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur son blog
ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon appelle les
adversaires internes de la nupesse il
cible je cite l'aile du PS elle l'aile
Jadot d'Europe Écologie Les Verts et
Fabien Roussel quand on regarde dans le
détail on se rend compte effectivement
que plusieurs grandes personnalités de
la nups non pas voté la motion c'est
donc le cas du patron du PC Fabien
Roussel en fait le groupe qui a le plus
fait défauts au moment du vote c'est le
groupe socialiste 12 députés socialistes
sur 31 non pas voté le texte parmi ces
élus on trouve notamment Valérie Rabault
l'ancienne rapporteur du budget et lundi
juste avant le vote le patron du parti
Olivier sort avait expliqué les
réticences socialistes sur la motion
écoutez
l'impression de censure est un argument
ultime à suggéré chaque semaine que le
gouvernement tombe sans que jamais il en
soit réellement menacé on prend le
risque d'affaiblir la force du message
et l'écho qu'il doit trouver dans
l'opinion le risque pris c'est celui
d'un brouhaha continu qui ne profitera
qu'à l'anti parlementarisme et ce
risque-là chacun ici doit le mesurer une
épaisse qui a donc été à nouveau mis à
l'épreuve avec cette motion mais qui
tient le coup sur les 151 députés de la
nups 129 ont voté la mention de censure
des insoumis les insoumis ont été 75 sur
75 à la beauté les socialistes 19 sur 31
les écolos 19 sur 23 les communistes 16
sur 22 la nuit peste tient bon c'est en
fait mais pour encore combien de motion
c'est toute la question mais Pierre
c'est la question pour combien de temps
encore ça peut tenir la nuit parce que
là c'est déjà un premier recrutement non
je crois pas là on est sur des sujets
d'ordre stratégique et c'est important
c'est que la stratégie
soit débattue et qui est des accords sur
la forme c'est à dire qu'il y a eu un
gros coup et où la nuit pêche avait fait
le plein sur la première motion de
censure ou toute la nuit pèse avait fait
bloc pour pour voter des sciences de ce
gouvernement là on est dans un débat qui
a vocation bon voilà il y a des 42 3
est-ce qu'on continue à faire des
émotions de défiance d'émotions de
censure sachant même qu'elles seront
jamais votées et avec en plus de ça la
polémique qui naît parce que l'extrême
droite voterai cette émotion je
comprends que des députés est pas très
envie de de s'inscrire dans un dans un
processus qui paraît un peu
rébarbatif redondant et au final bon bah
la voix c'est toujours la même voix qui
est portée ça fait jamais de mal un de
rappeler quels sont les engagements de
la nups parce que c'est ça qui est écrit
dans les textes c'est la question
écologique la question sociale la
question démocratique qui est portée à
chaque fois par cet ex-là donc ça me
paraît pas illogique qui est des débats
ça me paraît sain après on voit bien que
la réponse la raison pour laquelle à
certains nombre d'entre eux n'ont pas
voté le texte se joue pas sur des
questions de majorité
[Musique]
tranchant lui il prend pas beaucoup de
risques il est pas député le problème
c'est qu'il y en a beaucoup qui ne
votent pas la motion de censure parce
qu'ils savent qu'il s'exposent à une
dissolution et que de toute manière ils
seront pas réélu donc le problème de la
grande partie des de la plus grande
partie du immense majorité des députés à
l'Assemblée nationale qui soit de la
majorité ou de la gauche c'est que ils
savent très bien que s'ils vont à la
dissolution on va ressortir de là avec
une nouvelle élection législative qui va
apporter j'en suis absolument persuadé
une majorité relative offrant au
rassemblement national
des solutions parce qu'il est pas une
majorité pour un vote mais si la droite
déposant
à la dupesse avec l'apport des voix de
la race de rassemblement nationale il
pourrait très bien avec les lois du du
commande de LR aussi évidemment bien sûr
parce que c'est eux qui font la balance
ça n'arrivera jamais mais ça n'arrivera
probablement jamais on sait choisir
exactement
donc le problème si vous voulez que
c'est c'est là où ils sont bloqués c'est
non seulement le petit jeu de LR qui
sait pas trop où il habite ce parti et
puis deuxièmement c'est que beaucoup de
députés savent très bien que s'il
retourne devant les électeurs ils seront
pas élus ça c'est évident taché il y a
quelques minutes il disait mais la nuque
n'a pas intérêt à la dissolution on
n'est pas prêt si elle dissolution c'est
l'extrême droite qui va en bénéficier je
trouve ça toujours étonnant qu'un élu de
la République est toujours peur de se
soumettre suffrage c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné on est élu parce que il y a
une majorité de gens qui ont envie de
vous porter là où vous êtes aujourd'hui
donc le parlementaire qu'il est ne
devrait pas avoir la nupide et il dit on
n'est pas prêt ne devrait pas avoir peur
de revenir devant les yeux en revanche
je comprends et je je je partage sa
crainte qui est celle aujourd'hui d'une
extrême droite extrême forte et qui a
une dans un contexte compliqué on voit
encore aujourd'hui et pas que la France
de ce qui se passe à travers le monde en
Corée
avec l'Iran enfin bref tout ça par cible
d'atmosphère quand même assez anxiogène
donc ce contexte là me paraît pas non
plus le plus propice encore faut-il que
cette gauche la nups se conforte se
mobilise arrive à convaincre c'est ça
qu'il doit faire encore aujourd'hui donc
voilà je partage de la crainte qui est
la sienne d'une extrême droite très
forte et en même temps il ne devrait pas
avoir peur à partir devant les les
électeurs pour savoir si une majorité
peut s'exprimer en faveur de cette nuit
baisse est-ce que ça va profitera
rassemblement national est-ce que Marine
Le Pen en votant ces deux motions de la
nuque elle a réussi un coup politique ou
pas
réussi à coup politique c'est sûr que de
toute manière elle elle cherche à faire
comme disait Chevènement turbuler le
système c'est à dire que elle cherche à
brouiller les cartes et cherche
justement à diviser la gauche ça c'est
c'est absolument certain diviser la
nupesse et on le voit bien qu'il y a des
sensibilités c'est assez logique
d'ailleurs les sensibilités très
différentes la Lupette ça tient ça
repose pas sur sur grand chose c'est un
accord électoral d'abord donc bah
rassemble nationale le rassemblement
national joue là-dessus mais faut pas se
tromper non plus que le rassemblement
national c'est une personne c'est une
personnalité qui tire l'ensemble de de
du groupe je suis pas persuadé que si
vous voulez il y a une unité de
conviction il y a une unité aussi qui
est assez électoraliste à l'intérieur de
du rassemblement national mais c'est
vrai que ça fait le jeu ça fait du jeu
de et c'était la grande force de du
président de la République et de la
majorité c'est que il se retrouve avec
une opposition qui est extrêmement en
dépit de ces motions de censure qui
extrêmement divisée à affaiblir la nuque
selon vos pierres est-ce qu'elle réussit
à la diviser
j'en ai pas le sentiment c'est vrai que
je vois bien qu'il y a une
instrumentalisation politique de de la
nouvelle stratégie de la de l'extrême
droite de Marine Le Pen au sein du
Parlement à se montrer beaucoup plus
normal jouant le jeu des institutions
participants grâce à Emmanuel Macron
de fonctionnement de l'Assemblée
président et parce qu'ils voteraient des
textes de la nupesse il va aussi qu'ils
ont 89 députés
ils auraient pu empêcher l'élection de
deux représentants du rassemblement
national sur le père sur le poste de
vice-président il y avait une
possibilité c'était de choisir d'autres
candidats et qui avait et qui pouvaient
obtenir une majorité avec la gauche donc
c'est un choix des manuel Macron d'avoir
obtenu d'avoir monsieur Chenu par
exemple sur le perchoir qui anime les
débats au moment du vote sur le texte
budgétaire donc bon c'est un choix
politique qui dont ils devront assumer à
un moment donné aussi cette
responsabilité donc la normalisation
elle est pas le fait de la new peste
c'est si l'extrême droite de votre tête
de MIP c'est pas la responsabilité de la
nuit baisse si l'extrême droite le texte
d'Emmanuel Macron les textes de la
majorité présidentielle c'est pas le
fait de cette majorité présidentielle
donc à un moment donné non en revanche
il faut que la gauche effectivement dans
l'intitulé de ces textes quand elles
vont décrit des textes ça s'assure
qu'elle ne peut pas satisfaire un vote
de l'extrême droite encore plus ce qui
n'a pas fait encore que voilà mais on
sait que on sait que Marine Le Pen
l'assemblement national joue un jeu
délicat ou en tout cas de de
normalisation et qui qui qui les
conduisent à côté des textes avec
lesquels ils sont en totale désaccord
mais bon ça c'est pas on peut pas dire
que ce soit de la politique comme on
l'aime vraiment pas évidemment ce qui se
passe au Parlement
[Musique]